welcome to this video playing blind
guardian from Brazil young ok let's do
something else not the Queens gambit oh
he's a voluntarily going for very nice
version of the stone wall for white yeah
I don't mind that that's a very nice
position for white g4s one key point ok
so Queen takes or beat eggs it's both
good
B takes Idaho it's both both very good
White has a very nice position here with
them with advantage in the center the g
file open and play against against the
king that way came so 95 or not now it's
at least okay let's do it I know Quincy
3 also was interesting
hmm okay there should be five Bishop
f600 so maybe put some pressure on this
c5 Quincy six so that he cannot play
okay that's very typical just as I say
oh that that's that's totally impossible
and then they play it specially 5s as
possible Bishop b5 takes their chick
yeah almost it's almost possible
it is possible right or taking a long
time for those relatively simple tactics
okay so let's check I just want to take
or to have anything better probably not
this was the idea so that I get rook be
one book be 7n
Wow not be seven and rook da da well I'm
not quite sure actually I can also just
take of course rugby 758 end not quite
clear what I do after that ok I'm going
to take with that so that I maybe have
c4 to get a free d porn
hmm okay I didn't see that move at all
okay so he's getting rid of this this is
this bloody bishop
yeah you get some some nice activity
there with Lucas III
I don't know very strange what happens
here
if it takes 84 I wanted to go rook be 70
be should be six is also interesting but
rupee seven was my original intention
all right don't tell me that this is
still ok for black hair that I'm really
eating my head I have a couple of
containing bishop is six mate check mate
and Bishop g6 I mean don't tell me that
this is still ok from like you should be
five I can just take andrew create I
will take on g6 I guess
you should be 70
checkmate okay it wasn't very convincing
the opening is really really terrible
for like but he got some some kind of
position I mean he even played a 6 which
is kind of a nothing move sure maybe I
have something better yeah not taking
queen bee three is given by the engine
we are difficult I mean queen takes is
also much not totally off I mean yes to
take with the pawn it is also not a very
healthy porn okay this looks normal and
this old song yeah maybe is maybe 95 is
not that great yeah this is not possible
check check check check and made yes to
do this check then I chatted something
like that this is very very problematic
if he takes here for example I can't eat
with the bishop took me took a moment to
figure that out but it seems that this
is not that bad rook we sell more
stronger yeah I couldn't really I wasn't
sure I wasn't sure maybe it's just good
to insert insert the move and just then
just go from here it's certainly true
yeah this was strong I didn't see that
coming here for I know yes to take on d3
ad and I don't really know if this is
this is on okay King f8 supposed to be
good for black or equal at least
maybe this losers very difficult very
difficult stuff but at least I gotta go
to winning okay well thanks for watching